As with described in Birrell condition variables are synchronization constructs
which allow block threads to be notified once a specific condition occurs.
Birrell proposed the condition as condition variable abstraction as well as
three operations.
Weight, signal, and broadcast that can be performed on conditioned variables.
In pthreads condition variables are represented via
the designated condition variable data type.
The remaining operations align really well with Birrell's mechanisms.
For instance, for weight,
pthread has a pthread condition weight that takes two arguments,
a condition variable and a mutex, just like what we saw in Birrell's weight.
The semantics of this operation is also identical to Birrell's wait.
A thread that's entering the wait operation, a thread that must wait,
will automatically release the mutex and
place itself on the wait queue that's associated with the condition variable.
When the thread is woken up, it will automatically re-acquire the mutex before
actually exiting the wait operation.
This is identical to the behavior we saw in Birrell's wait.
Identical to the signal and broadcast mechanisms in Birrell, PThreads has.
Pthread condition signal and pthread condition broadcast,
that we can use to either notify one thread that's waiting on a condition
variable using the signal operation, or to notify all threads that are waiting
on a condition variable using the pthread condition broadcast operation.
There are also some other common operations that are used in
conjunction with condition variables.
These include the init and destroy functions.
Pthread_condition_init is pretty straight forward,
you have to use this operation in order to allocate the data structure for
the condition and in order to initialize it's attributes.
Like what we saw with mutexes.
The attributes can further specify the behavior that
pthreads provides with conditions.
For instance an example is whether or
not the conditions variable will be used only within threads that belong to
a single process or also shared across processes.
And similar to what we saw with the mutex and
threads attributes data structures.
Passing null in this call will result in
the default behavior that's supported by pthreads.
That happens to be that the condition variable is private to a process.
Just like threads condition variables should be explicitly freed and
reallocated, we use the condition destroy call for that.
And finally, a few pieces of advice regarding the use of condition variables.
First make sure you don't forget to notify the waiting threads.
Whenever any aspect off a predicate that some threads are waiting on change,
make sure that you signal or
broadcast the correct condition variables that these threads are waiting on.
Next, if you're ever in doubt whether you should use signal or
broadcast, use broadcast untill you figure out what the desired behaviour is.
Note that with broadcast you will lose performance.
So, make sure you use the correct notification mechanism, signal or
broadcast, when you need to wake up threads from a condition variable.
Remember, since you don't actually need the mutex to signal and broadcast,
it may be appropriate for you to remove that signal and broadcast operation.
Until after you've unlocked the mutex,
just like what we saw in the introductory lecture about threads.
We will point out some of these options during the discussion of
an actual pthreads example that we'll do next.